i remember filming my first dvd at the
manchester apollo
and i'm dead excited to be there it's
three thousand people i can't see
my i keep seeing this
[Laughter]
i look out and there's you know whatever
two thousand people
and my family are in it's over excited
and always you speak to any comment as
you know
you will always find the one person arms
folded
just giving it that light don't want to
be there checking his watch
upset he's missing the champions league
or whatever is it what
you know and he just wouldn't laugh this
guy at all and i couldn't get anything
out of him
and his camera's all over the place and
towards the end
he he giggles at something i can't
remember what it was but i remember he
just did like a little
whatever so a few weeks later we're in
the edit and we're putting the dvd
together
and i'm telling the editor about this
guy who ruined my night because i was
checking in on him
you know i was i remember do i do a joke
about
just every time and i'm telling the
editor this story about this guy and
we're sort of flicking through the
audience shots
and it cuts to this guy i said oh my god
this is the
this is the guy that like ruined my big
night because i couldn't i got obsessed
with why i wasn't laughing
and so we watched him for a little bit
just properly in a mood and as luck
would have it that one laugh that he
gave me
was caught on camera and he was a real
begrudging like
he might have just been laughing at
someone happened a few weeks ago
but in that moment i thought oh my god
we've got it so the it was the editor's
idea to be fair but we ran with it
that one laugh that he did on camera we
ended up using 23 times
so let's keep cutting back to this guy
and my dream my hope is that
at some point in the last 12 years he's
watching dave jarvoo
at two o'clock in the morning my show
comes on he watches it and gets to the
end and he thinks to himself
what a better night than i thought
[Music]
you